ils ont battu mon frère et lui entaché
les bras derrière le dos et l'ont tué de
treize coups de revolver torture prison
exécution voilà ce qu'ont subi des
milliers de brésiliens entre 64 et 85
pendant 21 ans de dictature militaire
tout commence avec le coup d'état de
1964 le putsch qui met fin à la
troisième république brésilienne pour
laisser place à un régime militaire
avec l'appui de la plupart des chefs
militaires
l'opposition vient de passer aux actes
partie de l'état de minas gerais la
rébellion a fait tâche d'huile jusqu'aux
portes du palais présidentiel que
monsieur roularta dû abandonner pour se
réfugier avec sa famille en uruguay la
gauche et neutraliser l'ennemi désormais
c'est le communisme ainsi que tous les
opposants en 1968 l'eta-militaire
anéanti la révolte étudiante mille
manifestants sont arrêtés et quatre sont
tués le brésil entre dans ces années de
plomb année marquée par le recours à la
torture
la femme patron de l'armée combat
actuellement bréville c'est réellement
la posture moi même j'ai été j'ai été
torturé très violemment pendant
e
un mois et demi torture surveillance
prison peine de mort pour éviter ce
destin la solution c'est l'exil
[Musique]
dans ces artistes et intellectuels
engagés ont choisi la france sans perdre
de vue la lutte trouve que vraiment il
faut rentrer il faut essayer de faire
même même si ça donne de la peur même
avec la peur dans le coeur toujours il
faut faire il faut rester là-bas y faire
quelque chose là-bas parce que si tout
le monde va qu'est ce que va rester là
bas qui va dégraisser labaki qui va
faire les choses il faut faire
mais tous n'ont pas pu s'exiler les
paysans mènent leur révolte sur place
dans les années 70 ils sont traqués sans
relâche
fait inédit l'église à l'origine rallier
aux militaires décident de lâcher l'état
pour leur porter secours
centre arriver là des policiers qui ont
commencé à maltraiter les personnes en
particulier cette dame essais ont
commencé à détruire la maison ont brûlé
4,5 votre maison et cela fait six mois
actuellement il n'y a pas encore de
possibilité pour eux de cultiver la
terre
l'êta militaire au brésil a pris fait en
1985 et la vérité sur les crimes commis
a mis du temps à éclore
bilan de ces années noires 434 morts ou
disparus ainsi que vingt mille personnes
victimes de la torture
[Musique]